le rejet de l'extrême droite avec une
forte mobilisation un peu partout en
france trente mille personnes à paris
pour protester contre le front national
et ceux qui ont été élue avec son
soutien
un rapport dénonce une pilule enfin
responsable de la mort de 30 personnes
dans le monde ce produit a été retiré du
circuit mais les victimes souffrent
d'effets secondaires importants
l'engouement des français pour le
jardinage la folie verte un site de les
grandes surfaces à ouvrir des rayons
spécifiques
le marché aux fleurs ou se demande par
internet notamment des millions de
plants en europe
le génie de magritte pour une
rétrospective exceptionnelle à bruxelles
l'univers surréaliste du peintre à
travers trois cent cinquante tableaux
l'ouverture sur les rêves
madame monsieur bonsoir pour faire
rempart à l'extrême droite contre le
front national et contre ceux qui ont
accepté les voix du parti de jean marie
le pen
la mobilisation de la rue à paris à
l'appel de la gauche plurielle de
différentes associations et syndicats
quelques trente mille personnes cet
après midi dans la capitale
françoise david alban nicosie berne
numério et les réparer ont retenti
aujourd'hui de ce bruit là plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes ont
répondu à l'appel du comité de vigilance
contre l'extrême droite pour dire non au
front national pour dire non aussi aux
alliances que certains dans la droite
parlementaire ont passé avec le parti de
jean marie le pen en tête du cortège une
banderole qui se voulait fédératrice
ensemble pour la liberté l'égalité et la
fraternité
le rappel des valeurs de la république
un peu plus loin les dirigeants des
organisations représentées au coude à
coude et notamment les politiques
je crois que ce sursaut est tout à fait
salutaire
je souhaite qu'il soit le plus large
possible je pense qu'il est une réponse
tumorale mais qu'il faut aussi une
réponse sociale
je crois que les françaises et les
français tous les républicains ont voulu
donner un signal très très fort en
disant que ce n'était plus possible
qu'il fallait arrêter ça elle souhaite
racisme aura le pont les organisations
étudiantes et lycéennes notamment
étaient largement représentés et c'est à
elle que revenait l'aspect le plus
dynamique du défilé d'autres mouvements
rompez avec leur discrétion habituelle
tels les francs maçons du grand orient
de france ont regretté un petit peu
quand on tour c'est ici beaucoup de gens
de gauche et finalement peu de gens de
droite je ne peux que regretter bien
évidemment que les reins ne soit pas si
serré pour défendre la république car
effectivement cet après midi les
manifestants venus à titre individuel se
disait majoritairement de gauche c'est
mon pays et je voudrais pas que mes deux
cases vitrolles s'étend à toute la
france les images de ces derniers temps
sont surtout pas celle que je veux
laisser transparaître dans le monde
entier devant ce qu'il considère comme
un grand succès les organisateurs ont
décidé de créer partout en france des
comités locaux de vigilance contre
l'extrême droite
alliant maintenant dès ce matin
plusieurs milliers de manifestants sont
descendus dans les rues pour protester
contre notamment l'élection de charles
million à la présidence et de la région
rhône alpes avec les voix du front
national conduit par les élus de la
gauche plurielle ou conseil régional le
cortège portait des banderoles comme f
comme fasciste n comme nazi
des mots d'ordre identique et à toulouse
avec une même détermination en tête du
cortège une banderole toulouse dit non
au fn là aussi les manifestants
répondaient à l'appel de plusieurs
associations syndicats et partis de
gauche
pour finir ce tour d'horizon
manifestation à strasbourg cet après
midi quelques milliers de personnes
autour du collectif justice et libertés
qui on s'en souvient avait organisé une
immense manifestation en mars 97 contre
la tenue d'un congrès front national
dans la ville
et puis à montpellier là aussi très
forte mobilisation près de 14000
personnes pour dénoncer la présence du
front national l'a aussi dans les
exécutifs de la région et réclamer
bruyamment la démission de jacques blanc
une singularité dans ce cortège la
détermination des artistes dont la
colère grandit après que le front
national est réclamé ces jours ci la fin
de la dictature culturel de la gauche
car inkomazi pascal pons les
organisateurs espéraient 10 mille
personnes se sont en fait près de 15000
manifestants qui ont réclamé la
démission du président jacques blanc élu
à la région avec les voix du front
national
enseignants retraités étudiants des
dizaines de formations se sont jointes
aux syndicats et aux élus de la majorité
mais c'est au milieu du cortège que la
colère est la plus grande
les artistes de la région sont venus
protester contre les déclarations du
leader local du front national qui
réclame la suppression de leur
subvention en rappelant à chaque blanc
ses engagements contre la dictature
cultural de gauche
il importe que nous cessions de faire
que les associant les associations
culturelles couche avec le maire de
montpellier georges frêche et que ce
soit jacques blanc le président de la
région qui paye la chambre rappelle à
l'ordre rejetée par jacques blanc qui
souligne qu'il est le seul maître du jeu
plus long la dictature de la gauche mais
nous refusons toutes les dictatures
je suis ici le garant de la liberté
je veux défendre l'ensemble des acteurs
de la culture contre toutes les terreurs
et tout lé terrorisme
une parade contre la dictature de gauche
que les artistes récuse au nom de leur
liberté d'opinion de pensée raisonnée à
gauche je n'y peux rien c'est comme ça
or en 1930 et aux 30 points quand on a
choisi autant que l'on parle de berlin
on disait qu'ils étaient juifs en
battant une bouche on connaît et qu'il
répandait la culture de boucheron
connaissent de la même chose l'histoire
repasse les plats que ces brins de ce
blanc se rend pas compte qu'il fallait
avec les bruns la manifestation s'achève
mais le collectif des artistes entend
occuper le terrain jusqu'à la démission
du président jacques blanc c'est
peut-être une longue résistance qui
commence aujourd'hui
et puis sur l'ensemble de ces
manifestations les réactions de bruno
mégret numéro 2 du front national qui
dénonce je le cite le caractère
insurrectionnel de ces manifestations
qui constitue un danger pour la
démocratie
en picardie c'est dans la nuit que
finalement quatre vice présidente est
élu au troisième tour où conseil
régional avec les voix du front national
après une séance houleuse que nous vous
montrions dès hier soir
ce matin se tenait le conseil national
du parti socialiste à l'ordre du jour
notamment la situation créée par les
alliances politiques entre une partie de
la droite et le front national lors des
régionales françois hollande a par
ailleurs indiqué que le premier ministre
s'exprimera après les consultations qui
commenceront lundi et qui amèneront
jacques chirac pendant une dizaine de
jours a rencontré l'ensemble des
responsables des partis politiques à
l'exception du front national et puis
avoue encore de politique avec ce
sondage ifop/journal du dimanche avec
pour lionel jospin une cote de
popularité plutôt stable 50% de
satisfaits les mécontents passe de 38 à
32 %
quant à jacques chirac que rechute en
mars 47 % se disent satisfaits du
président de la république contre 54%
février 38 % de mécontents contre 33 le
mois précédent voilà pour la politique
un rapport
expertise dénoncent la dangerosité d'un
couffin mis sur le marché en 86 et qui
aura entraîné la mort de 30 personnes de
par le monde cette pilule l'isoméride a
été prescrite à 7 millions de personnes
en france son efficacité certaine
mais ces effets secondaires dans des cas
extrêmes sont à l'origine de maladies
cardiaques et pulmonaires très grave se
produit a été retiré totalement du
marché en septembre dernier
reste les victimes reportage daniel
wolfromm marques millet cette jeune
femme n'a franchement pas de chance elle
a contracté une maladie rare et grave
l'hypertension artérielle pulmonaire
après un traitement amaigrissant à
l'isoméride un médicament coupe faim
une centaine de cas similaires ont été
décelés en france depuis 1985
anna est bien décidé à prendre ses
affaires en main son histoire à elle
remonte à 1991 quand son médecin lui
recommande tout simplement de perdre
quelques kilos après son accouchement un
quinze jours j'ai perdu 6 kg et après ce
qui s'est passé et après j'ai commencé à
être à essouffler je faisais comme des
crises d'asthme et pendant longtemps on
est médecin et les enclos que je faisais
de l'asthme jusqu'au jour où j'ai fait
un malaise je rêvais à l'hôpital on
m'avait dit que c'était pas du tout au
delà
ensuite ils m'ont annoncé qu'ils me
fallait une greffe des poumons
parce qu'il n'y avait pas de guérison
pour cette maladie et elle était arrivée
avec un final je vais pas plus longtemps
à dire qu'est ce que vous allez faire
maintenant bien maintenant j'essaye de
me battre pour que ce seront 10 tous se
battent pour la polo c'est aller devant
les tribunaux un rapport d'experts
saisis l'an dernier vient de rendre des
conclusions qui lui sont favorables
à l'heure actuelle son hypertension
pulmonaire compte tenu de l'absence de
tout incident chez cette femme doit être
lié à l'isoméride et la littérature
médicale formelle à ce sujet par contre
le laboratoire servier fabricant du
médicament ni le lien de causalité entre
l'isoméride et la maladie d' anna lisa
mérite comme le pondéral présentés comme
des produits miracles ont été consommés
par des millions de patients en
france l'obésité touche 7 à 10% de la
population l'isoméride a été absorbée
pendant dix ans sans modération mais 95
une étude internationale incriminent les
coupes faim dans les hypertensions
artérielles
les premiers les français prennent des
mesures l'isoméride est massivement
retiré de la vente et n'est plus
délivrés que pour des cas d'obésité
majeur en 97
le produit disparaisse complètement du
marché mondial nous avons envoyé depuis
le début de l'année dernière aux
médecins une circulaire pour qu'il nous
dise si dans leur clientèle certains
pourraient être victimes de ces
médicaments
il faut pour rassurer les gens dire que
ces atteintes là c'est à dire
l'hypertension pulmonaire en particulier
survient en général dans la première
année de consommation
cette coupe faim reste sur le marché
aujourd'hui ils sont réservés aux
obésité pathologique sous strict
contrôle médical et pour des périodes
très limité à l'occasion du salon
mondial du tourisme les professionnels
mettent en garde contre le tourisme
sexuel sur place un stand spécifique
tenu par une organisation ni d'heure
entre la prostitution des enfants dans
le monde son but
impliquer les agences de tourisme pour
convaincre voire même dissuader les
clients de se rendre dans des pays comme
la thaïlande ou les philippines où ces
pratiques condamnées y compris au plan
local sont courantes
reportage alain douguet ce qui réunira
métaoui c'est un signe très clair au
salon mondial du tourisme la lutte
contre le tourisme sexuel a désormais
droit de cité
deux millions d'enfants dans le monde
sont concernés par la prostitution
brésil plus bas vietnam europe de l'est
mais surtout philippines et thaïlande
ces deux derniers pays ont renforcé leur
législation locale
les autorités y militent aujourd'hui
contre ces pratiques
c'est pas bon et c'est non c'est pas
juste c'est notre moyen d'exploitation
les amateurs de ce type de tourisme ont
besoin d'information les brochures de
vacances les guides touristiques
désormais participer à la campagne de
sensibilisation en publiant des mises en
garde des entraînements clairement
position une morale est clair depuis une
dizaine d'années on dénonce ce genre de
choses comme la on le dénonce également
à phnom penh au cambodge où le tourisme
monsieur sexuelle est en train de
devenir à grands pas malheureusement les
agences de voyages ont le sentiment
d'être impuissante devant ces pratiques
pour le personnel déterminer le profil
du client est souvent bien difficile
ça ne s'est pas écrit sur une étiquette
qui va dans ce but
je pense que maintenant chacun dans nos
agences et à ses responsables de vendre
ne pas vendre un forfait ou un billet
d'avion parce que sous fermons la porte
à ce genre de touristes savons très bien
que notre porte s'ouvrir sous une zone
savons tous cas ça peut me dhabi on peut
être vendus par d'autres biais le viè
téléphone devient
mail à tous les échelons les
professionnels du tourisme affirment
avoir pris conscience du problème la loi
qui permet de poursuivre dans leur
propre pays
les voyageurs ayant commis des abus
sexuels à l'étranger devrait faciliter
leur travail au sénat aujourd'hui 300
élèves de 3e venus de toute la france
ont voté dans l'hémicycle du palais du
luxembourg la charte du jeune citoyen de
l'an 2000
ces sénateurs junior particulièrement
impliqué en cette journée une
manifestation contre l'extrême droite
avec l'adoption d'un article affirmant
que le racisme est une attitude
incompatible avec les valeurs de la
république éric lemasson
la démocratie c'est comme l'orthographe
il y a les règles à apprendre les pièges
à éviter et les travaux pratiques
leçon numéro un la politique c'est
sérieux nicolas 14 ans de bordeaux a été
choisi par ses camarades dans
l'hémicycle dit à l'heure il sera
rapporteur pour défendre la proposition
de leur commission environnement
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
nous avons retenu le texte de la
proposition du menu de toute la france
300 élèves de troisième sont invités à
faire la loi
ordre du jour l'adoption de la charte du
jeune citoyen de l'an 2000
leçon numéro 2 la politique c'est
compliqué
c'est assez difficile de décider pour
les autres parce qu' on essaie de
choisir pour les autres et je trouve ça
un peu difficile de choisir par rapport
à nous par rapport à ce que nous envient
mais on peut pas on n'a pas en tête la
possibilité de juger par rapport aux
autres lap certes mais au fait petite
interrogation écrite avant les meetings
auxquels et le président du sénat
leçon numéro 3 la politique c'est propre
le débat ne doit souffrir d'aucune
compromission ni coup bas
seuls comptent les idées et les idéaux
la parole est aux sénateurs samy 15 ans
guyane
le racisme est une attitude est active
avec les valeurs de la république qui
sont la liberté l'égalité et la
fraternité
aujourd'hui il faut vigoureusement
lutter contre le racisme dans un
contexte où malheureusement certains
partis politiques ken de propos
inadmissibles
mais les hommes politiques qu'est ce que
tu penses de leur attitude en général
qui parce qu'ils ont envie de faire mais
ce qui les arrange de faire et ce qu'ils
peuvent faire sur les moyens qu'ils ont
donc dû parti change pas vraiment leur
leurs idées ils souffrent ils font score
lorsqu'on leur dit quoi il décide pas
eux-mêmes donc il décide en groupe et
s'ils sont pas d'accord mais tant pis
chez vos mouvements
la leçon numéro 4 c'est donc nicolas qui
a tout compris qui nous l'a souffle la
politique c'est effectivement comme
l'orthographe il y à la règle à suivre
il y a aussi des exceptions je vous
propose maintenant l'enquète de ce
journal le nouvel engouement des
français pour le jardinage véritable
antidote à la morosité un loisir un
passe temps particulièrement adaptés ces
jours ci avec l'arrivée du printemps
un marché aux fleurs particulièrement
lucratif puisque les grandes surfaces ce
équipe désormais 10 passes réservés
reportage frédéric dupuy et guillaume
fautrat achètent aujourd'hui quel gros
gégé sur j'achète toute la semaine je
vais venir acheter tout le printemps
l'achète je toujours après d'acheter
le printemps la ruée vers l'or vert
fleurs coupées plantes vertes bulbeuses
en tout genre et nains de jardin la
nouvelle passion frénétique des français
aujourd'hui c'est d'abord avec son
caddie que l'on jardine direction la
grande distribution les plantes à côté
du poisson ici le jardin une véritable
industrie que c'est un commerce comme un
autre une industrie
c'est un peu choquant vis-à-vis des
fleurs mais c'est pas commerce important
grand et petit revenu pour des jardins
ou des balcons tout le monde achète les
français ont dépensé 31 milliards et
demi de francs pour leurs plantes en une
année c'est trois fois moins que le
bricolage
juste un peu moins que les dépenses
hi-fi et télé et autant que le sport
tout commence ici près d'amsterdam
on
le plus grand entrepôt du monde
il peut contenir plus de 600 terrains de
football 70 % du marché français passent
par ici
levet ligne le wall street des fleurs et
plantes la salle des marchés les fleurs
défilent sous le regard des courtiers
on juge de la qualité on écoute les prix
on achète avant l'autre pour ce matin
j'ai de la rose assorti
oui à 44,500 la société mauvrit acheter
ce matin 85 mille roses elle les vendra
en france et dans le monde entier le
jour même car les fleurs c'est
périssable
oui chez nous en voyons des images de
nos bouquets sur internet en un quart
d'heure nos clients dans le monde entier
peuvent voir nos produits pour nous
c'est très rapide et très facile à faire
jj floch pour répondre aux besoins du
marché les fleurs ont été standardisés
elles ont la même taille le même âge et
poussettes en musique
le marché est encore loin d'être saturé
il reste de l'argent à gagner
le nombre de jardinerie explose truffaut
plus d'un milliard de chiffre d'affaires
s'est installée en plein paris au milieu
du béton peu de jardin dans la capitale
et pourtant ça marche
un exemple suivi henry delbard occupera
bientôt la gare de l'est sur 2500 mètres
carrés il ya des problèmes de plus en
plus forts de plus en plus nombreux on
est triste on a du chômage
on a besoin de compenser et on compense
dans la fleur dans le beau et le jardin
est un univers privilégié de dans ce
sens après une semaine d'ouverture ce
magasin de clermont ferrand réalise
trois cent mille francs de chiffre
d'affaires en 1 samedi
un concept original la jardinerie est
aussi un lieu de promenade pour la
famille créer un petit peu la campagne à
la vue zurich nous et dans les hlm comme
cette mère et sa fille qui repartent le
caddie rempli
victor renoue consomme le jardin sa
grande passion depuis plus de 30 ans
aujourd'hui ils cassent lui aussi sa
tirelire vous voulez parler de ma chair
bien entendu
alors oui la recherche est un gros
investissement mais marianne a quand
même pour 15000 francs
un peu plus même avec les accessoires
parfums fauchère un dépliant dans la vie
un petit plaisir dans la vie que
beaucoup veulent vivre sans effort on
veut du verre avant tout même s'il n'a
plus rien de naturel l'artificiel
représente déjà 10% du marché des fleurs
et plantes des fleurs lavables et
éternelle de quoi laisser certains
rêvaient depuis hier à genève se tient
le salon des inventeurs véritable
pépinière de l'astuce de la créativité
avec bien sûr son lot de professeur
nimbus l'exemple de cet inventeur primé
l'an dernier pour avoir mis au point un
pot d'échappement catalytiques son
parcours pour tenter de protéger son
invention et de la commercialiser claude
crespo arg motte
ces cailloux bleus ont valu à roger
touati une médaille d'argent à genève
l'an dernier il a mis deux points un pot
d'échappement anti pollution qui l'a
aussitôt baptisé mandoline
son idée est simple ces minéraux
remplace la céramique des classiques
pots catalytiques
vous avez des minéraux qui bloque les
gaz à plusieurs endroits les force à des
révolutions sans arrêt sans armes et
sans l'arrêt jusqu'à la sortie et c'est
pourquoi on peut l'être et
éventuellement ce film peut être adaptée
tout type de vie durée de vie 208
kilomètres
selon son inventeur élimination jusqu'à
90 % de la pollution attestée par une
cinquantaine de contrôle en 2d coût 30 %
moins cher qu'un pot catalytique
ordinaire après l'invention sa
protection
avec l'enregistrement du brevet ce
cabinet en propriété industrielle a fait
sa spécialité il reçoit par an une
soixantaine l'inventeur tout commence
par la rédaction du projet un dossier
très fouillée très précis avec she
mazella depuis c'est lui qui empêcherait
une éventuelle confrontation
cette protection est d'enregistrer un
institut national de la propriété
industrielle et dans tous les pays où le
brevet étendue votre invention et elle
protège et apparemment et pour moi oui
dans quel pays
pour l'instant on a demandé l'extension
je crois à 94 pays différents jusqu'à
quand sur 20 ans et combien cela va
coûter jusqu'à présent chaque seconde
pour l'instant autour de cinq ans une
francs dernière étape pour roger touati
l'industrialisation de sa mandoline
conséquence de genève
il est actuellement pour parler et ils
voient l'avenir en rose il est environ 5
millions et demi de véhicules équipés en
france
en attendant la fortune son cerveau
continue de générer une idée par jour
dernière trouvaille la création sur
internet d'une pinacothèque avec les
peintres du monde entier tombés dans le
domaine public
non seulement on peut la consulter mais
aussi se faire livrer chez soi une copie
de ses toiles avec le cadre contre
environ 6000 francs à ce jour il n'en a
vendu aucune à l'étranger l'ancien
premier ministre russe victor
tchernomirdine congé n'y ait brutalement
en début de semaine par boris elstine
annoncé son intention de se présenter à
l'élection présidentielle de l'an 2000
lors d'un entretien à la télévision cet
homme âgé de 59 ans et qui a passé les
cinq dernières années au gouvernement
s'est porté candidat à la succession
veltin la turquie après avoir il ya
quelques semaines interdit le parti
islamique leur effa continue de lutter
contre le fondamentalisme dans ce pays
partagé entre des mouvements laïcs et
religieux le pouvoir appellent à deux
nouvelles lois contre les islamistes le
port du voile dans les universités et
les administrations seraient interdits
reportage philippe rochot pour mettre au
pas les islamistes la police turque
envoie les chiens suprême injure chez
les musulmans pour qui cet animal est un
pur mais cette mosquée de beyazit à
istanbul est le symbole de l'épreuve de
force contre les fondamentalistes qui
pris ici chaque vendredi à présent
l'armée va contrôler les institutions
qui soutiennent les intégristes
musulmans
la construction de mosquées sera soumise
à autorisation les émissions religieuses
surveiller mais les islamistes ici
n'appelle pas à la lutte armée
l'islam c'est pas c'est pas la révolte
de l'islam valait pas telle qu'elle est
vers l'armée telle qu'elle est le
système tel qu'il est la seule chose qui
nous veulent c'est d'entrer dans le
système
les islamistes doivent pourtant accepté
que les femmes voilées soit interdite
dans l'administration turque ainsi que
dans les universités
deux mois après avoir dissout le parti
islamiste ref à l'armée turque enfonce
le clou pour contourner l'interdiction
son chef
necmettin erbakan interdit de politique
pour cinq ans vient de fonder un autre
parti le parti de la vertu avec des
hommes à lui et les islamistes
continuent leur action sociale en
distribuant chaque jour quelques 2000
repas aux déshérités dans les mosquées
comme le fait ici la municipalité
islamistes d'istanbul
c'est le meilleur moyen de garder le
contact avec une population qui les a
portés en masse à l'assemblée nationale
mais nous battons uniquement pour aider
les gens sans distinction de parti donc
même si le parti répète à présent fermé
et que naît un autre parti saba nous
voulons dire ce que nous dépendons
uniquement de la mairie d'istanbul et
que nous continuerons notre action
l'action sociale des islamistes n'a pas
d'étiquette politique
l'armée turque qui défend la laïcité de
l'état aura du mal à se battre sur ce
terrain or c'est par ces campagnes de
soutien aux déshérités que les
islamistes avaient réussi à devenir la
première formation politique du pays
les partisans de la légalisation du
cannabis dans les rues de londres cet
après-midi la plus grande manifestation
pro cannabis jamais organisé depuis 30
ans les manifestants n'ont pas hésité à
fumer ouvertement devant les forces de
police onze mille personnes dont des
malades souffrant de sclérose en plaques
ou du sida qui ont déclaré utiliser le
cannabis contre la douleur et l'anxiété
une manifestation soutenue par paul
mccartney ou encore le pdg de virgin
richard branson
aux etats unis un infirmier californien
pourrait avoir tué une quarantaine de
personnes dit il
pour des raisons humanitaires la sphère
et complexe une enquête a été ouverte à
partir de ses aveux de nombreux dossiers
hospitaliers seront épluchés pour savoir
comment sont décédés les patients de cet
hôpital de la région
correspondance philippe gassot
l'infirmier de glendale dans la banlieue
de los angeles a été entendu pendant
quarante huit heures par la police et
laissé en liberté il faudra sans doute
plusieurs mois aux enquêteurs
compte tenu du nombre des victimes entre
40 et 50 pour y voir plus clair
les investigations sont impliqués et
elle demande de nombreuses auditions et
aussi d'importantes recherches dans les
archives de l'hôpital
l'infirmier semblait observé une sorte
d'éthique il mettait fin uniquement à
l'existence de malades en phase
terminale ayant demandé expressément
qu'il n'y ait pas d'acharnement pour les
maintenir en vie
pour le frère de l'accusé l'infirmier
n'est pas coupable et ce cas il a un
vrai sens médical parce qu'il aime aider
les gens ce n'est pas un tueur une façon
singulière pourtant d'aider les gens
efren saldivar l'infirmier aurait avoué
avoir agi pour des raisons humanitaires
les enquêteurs ont investi les locaux du
centre médical pour le moment
officiellement la police procède à des
vérifications mais n'est pas en mesure
de préciser si un ou des crimes ont
véritablement été commis ici ni pourquoi
retour en france en matière de mode elle
les principales évolutions de ces
dernières années touche la matière et
les tissus après la révolution du nil en
plus du lycra voyant les nouvelles
pistes que les chercheurs explorent
reportage ce film est l pascal couillaud
6 tonnes au point d'impact
ici les tissus ont la vie dure martyrisé
sans une minute de répit
brûlé à vif déchiré sauvagement raboter
jusqu'à la corde pour qu'ils livrent
leurs secrets
c'est dans ses laboratoires de la
banlieue lyonnaise que les chercheurs
planchent sur six tissu qu'on dit
intelligent
les scientifiques affinity si par
exemple un greffage antiseptique
destinée à empêcher toute contamination
microbienne les staphylocoques se
tiennent à distance
une manne pour les sportifs qui trouve
déjà sur le marché sous vêtements et
chaussettes garantie anti odeurs le
traitement plasma n'en est encore qu'à
ses balbutiements
un échantillon du tissu béni de gaz
pendant quelques secondes et miracle une
laine qui ne réussit plus aux lavages
après traitement plasma on peut obtenir
une bonne résistance est donc une bonne
stabilité dimensionnelle
comme on peut le voir la différence
entre les deux est champion
pénétration dans l'air résistance au
froid extrême ce sont les sportifs qui
font le plus avancé la recherche textile
martin dans son caisson se gèle les
capteurs par -20° des nouveaux matériaux
à changement de phase en caisse les
chocs thermiques à sa place avec des
équipes scientifiques nationales ou
internationales à des textiles plus
intelligent des textiles qui sont
capables de réagir par rapport à
l'environnement en se modifiant par
rapport aux contraintes de
l'environnement
on peut rêver à des textiles qui on
serait s'autoréparer aux settons
cicatriser après avoir subi des
endommagements ses professeurs nimbus du
chiffon reste encore de tissus
chatoyants mais sans colorant qui
s'inspirait du reflet de la lumière sur
des ailes de papillons des tofs
autonettoyante de tissu qui plongerait
la pollution ou encore de maillots peau
de requin pourfendre les eaux avec
quelques centièmes d'avancé
prochaine étape un saut vertigineux 48 m
ar - 60 degrés les scientifiques
travaillent sur une combinaison
stratosphérique totalement étanche un
délire qui devrait rejaillir sur toute
l'industrie textile jacques chirac
aujourd'hui a reçu à l'elysée les
médaillés olympiques de nagano remise
que les prix de décoration avec d'abord
la surfeuse karine ruby première
médaille française the sea première
médaille d'or
le président déclaré que cette moisson
de l'hiver était une bonne moisson
distinguant la performance de jean luc
crétier première victoire olympique
française en descente depuis 30 ans puis
jacques chirac s'est adressé à philippe
candeloro qui l'a félicité pour ce
superbe personnage de d'artagnan un
grand coup de coeur a commenté le chef
de l'état le trophée de la coupe du
monde de football démarre une tournée
dans 15 villes de france c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire de la
coupe du monde qu'un tel événement est
organisé le trophée présentait certes
une réplique exacte en acquéreur de
l'original
actuellement dit en place et sous bonne
garde et c'est cette réplique qui sera
exposée dans un camion spécialement
aménagé à marseille dans le petit
quartier de l'estaque toute l'équipe du
film marius et jeannette de primes et
aux césar s'est retrouvé autour d'un
immense aïoli pour célébrer à leur façon
la réussite du film auquel ils ont
associé les habitants du quartier chaque
quart dos vincent deux ombres la scène
se déroule à l'alhambra petit cinéma de
quartier de l'estaque
c'est ici qu'a rien ascaride et sa bande
de copains se sont retrouvés pour
célébrer le succès du film mais si ça
hyper aïoli pour tout le monde pour les
300 invités de l'estac
cette fête c'est un peu leur césar
l'occasion d'évoquer leur quartier c'est
la vie naturelle du parti tout
simplement un c'était très bien retracée
est abîmée et
et s'il en passe de nous tous
quartier les taxes et le nombril du
monde il est passé des plus grands
artistes l'estac des peintres images
d'epinal car le chômage et la pauvreté
traverse aussi ce petit village du bout
de marseille où les derniers bidonvilles
ont été rasés il ya peu un quotidien qui
évoque aussi le film donne moi tes
papiers je te dis quoi toi on a le droit
de d'avoir un biais aussi de voir du
cinéma authentique voir qu'ils parlent
des gens qui parlent de leur vie au
quotidien de leurs problèmes et de
comment peuvent aussi les surmonter pour
tous la boucle est bouclée
l'histoire se termine ici autour de 7 à
you lie point de départ d'une nouvelle
aventure
la culture russe à l'honneur à paris
pendant 15 jours les artistes les plus
talentueux et dans toutes les
disciplines sont de passage en france
l'occasion de découvrir l'une des plus
grandes danseuses classiques du monde
dans un pays où la tradition du bal est
qu a fait sa renommée reportage olivier
léglise à frédéric bonnet
elle sculpte les sentiments humains avec
grâce et rapidement beaucoup une pureté
esthétique ces qualités se rapproche de
notre art de la danse ou la place était
très important nina annan yachvili la
super star incontestée du ballet
classique selon la presse américaine est
présente à paris pendant deux jours
accueilli sur toutes les scènes du monde
la première danseuse étoile du bolchoï
interpréter le rôle titre dans le lac
des cygnes
la belle au bois dormant promeo juliette
une carrière exemplaire pour l'héritière
de toute une tradition ou avons connu en
est une dans ce serait pure une danse de
soviétiques telle qu'on l'entendait dans
les années 60
un rêve de japon un ballet en un acte
interprété par les danseurs du bolchoï
une création mise en lumière par nina
l'enfant de tbilissi devenue une reine
en géorgie impossible pour elle de
promener sa frimousse dans le monde sans
être reconnu par un compatriote serbe
nina c'est la géorgie grâce à la beauté
la santé rencontrés dans le jardin
français
le badaud est fier la jeune femme elle
s'est déjà envolé dans son rêve rêve de
japon le rêve d'une petite fille devenue
danseuse étoile et qui possède le génie
de s'isoler avec tout et si les recoins
de l'âme remarquable exposition magritte
à bruxelles pour le centenaire du
peintre la plus belle rétrospective
jamais organisée avec près de 350
tableau qui nous permettent de découvrir
l'univers surréaliste de cet artiste de
génie change veygoux pascal peyo
ceci n'est pas un pâtre parce que parce
que ceci n'est pas une pipe avec
magritte il faut se méfier des évidences
son oeuvre a de quoi vous faire perdre
la boule et le chapeau le poète est il à
ce point d'istres est qu'ils peignent un
ciel de jour sur une ville dans la nuit
il vit modestement dans une petite
maison bourgeoise et quand il fait son
cinéma surréaliste
il n'a qu'une actrice sa femme georgette
épouse est très jeune et qui sera son
unique compagne
ça c'est le cavaliere
magritte aime la musique populaire et
particulièrement le cube
il trouve cet instrument érotique et ça
lui donne des idées
challenge là
rythme viendra la reconnaissance
internationale qu'après cinquante jusque
là pour vivre ils pas des affiches
publicitaires et l'on peut dire que nos
créatifs publiciste d'aujourd'hui lui
sont tous redevables
car il est le seul peintre de l'histoire
de l'art à matérialiser dessinée crois
qu'il restera un grand patriote un
deuxième set parce que outre cette image
il ya surtout de mystère et que le
mystère effet malgré qu'il a voulu tel
quel il a voulu que ce mystère est
incompréhensible
il n'a pas voulu expliquer ce mystère
mystère du visible cacher une pomme
obsessionnel que d'envahir tout
l'appartement un tableau toujours en
cacher un autre
tout en demeurant une seule et unique
image vous ferez sûrement quelques pas
dans les nuages si vous vous rendez à
bruxelles visitez le bonhomme magritte
c'est la fin de ce journal je vous
rappelle le principal titre le rejet de
l'extrême droite avec une forte
mobilisation un peu partout en france
trente mille personnes à paris pour
protester contre le front national et
ceux qui ont été élue avec son soutien
et puis n'oubliez pas que cette nuit
nous passons à l'heure d'été à 2 heures
il sera 3 heures du matin dans un
instant la météo de nathalie rihouet
dégradation par l'ouest températures
douces ce 20h55 la fiesta patrick
sébastien de master dans thé ou café
catherine ceylac reçoit daniel gélin
amylie pollinique que michèle cotta aura
comme invité jean christophe cambadélis
député socialiste de paris et philippe
douste-blazy député udf des hautes
pyrénées
je vous remercie de votre attention j'en
ai le plaisir de vous retrouver demain
soir à 20h excellente de fin de soirée
sur france 2
je